DOING THE SAME.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN CALLING OUT
TWITTER SAYING, TWITTER BANDS
POLITICAL ADS AND YET ANOTHER
ATTEMPT BY THE LEFT IS TO
SILENCE TRUMP AND CONSERVATIVES.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED TWITTER
LIFTED THE BAN AFTER 2020.
OKAY.
LET'S TAKE AROUND THE TABLE.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT HALLOWEEN
CANDY DURING THE BREAK AND, I
GOT OFF TRACK.
>> YOU ARE TRYING TO BRING UP
SOME KIND OF CONCERN FOR THE
STORY.
THAT'S THE STANDPOINT OF, DO YOU
THINK IT'S GOOD FOR PUBLIC
DEBATE, OR TO HAVE A DEBATE
ABOUT FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION?
BECAUSE BASICALLY YOU HAVE TWO
OF THE BIGGEST TECH COMPANIES
TAKING VERY DIFFERENT OPINIONS
ON THIS.
>> I THINK IT'S EXCELLENT.
I THINK IT'S INTERESTING THAT
JACK DORSEY HAS TAKEN SUCH AN I
AM THE ANTI-FACEBOOK STANCE AND
I AM THE ANTIDOTE, WE DO IT SO
MUCH BETTER HERE AND THERE ARE
LOTS OF FUNDAMENTAL FLAWS WITH
HIS REASONING.
FOR EXAMPLE THE FACT THAT THEY
HAVE NOW BANNED ISSUE ADS ALSO
AND THAT WILL LIKELY -- >> HOW
DO YOU DECIDE TO.
>> WATCH YOUR MOUTH.
THAT'S 5:00.
>> THAT MUST HAVE HURT.
>> WHAT'S A STICKY WICKET?
>> OH, IT'S AN ADVOCACY ADDED.
SO TO ME, LET'S START AT .0,
WHICH IS I THINK THAT JACK
DORSEY MUST WATCH "THE FIVE" ON
MARK ZUCKERBERG MUST NOT BECAUSE
I DON'T SEE WHY YOU DON'T JUST
DO AWAY WITH POLITICAL ADS.
BECAUSE IT IS NEGLIGIBLE IN
TERMS OF THEIR BOTTOM LINE.
AND, THE REALITY IS THAT
ZUCKERBERG DOESN'T SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
THAT HE IS UNDERMINING HIS BRAND
BY ALLOWING POLITICAL LIES TO BE
PUT ON HIS PLATFORM.
THAT TO ME LESSENS THE TRUST
THAT THE CONSUMER HAS.
WE HAVE A VERY STRONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH FACEBOOK AS IT
GETS PERSONAL, FRIENDS AND
FAMILY.
AND NOW YOU SAY THERE ARE
POLITICAL LIES.
>> BUT WHO GETS TO DECIDE WHAT'S
A LIE AND WHAT'S NOT?
>> IT'S ACTUALLY ANOTHER WAY TO
GET INFORMATION AND THEY WOULD
LIKE THAT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO -- PUT TRUMP
SLIDES THERE PLEASE.
>> I DIDN'T EVEN REALIZE THERE
WERE ADS ON TWITTER.
I DON'T SEE THEM, ALL I SEE IS
PEOPLE SCREAMING AT EACH OTHER.
TWITTER'S UPDATES ARE DOWN 95%.
IF YOU MADE $100 LAST YEAR YOU
MADE FIVE THIS YEAR.
I ACTUALLY WORKED IT OUT.
NO ONE WANTS TO GET NEAR THIS
TANGLED PILE OF SCREAMERS
BECAUSE TWITTER AS WE KNOW HAS
BEEN AN AMPLIFIED EDGE OF THIS
COURSE.
IF THEY ARE DUE ALMOST ALL THE
TWEETING AND THEY ARE DESCRIBED
AS POLITICALLY ACTIVE AND LEFT
LEANING.
WHAT YOU ARE BASICALLY GETTING
IS A CAMPUS SIT IN EVERY TIME
YOU WATCH TWITTER.
>> IT ISN'T -- WHEN YOU GO ON
FACEBOOK IT'S UP FUN PLAT ROOM,
COME PLATFORM.
IS HE YOUR FAMILY AND YOUR
FRIENDS, YOU WONDER WHAT YOU ARE
DOING AND THINKING ABOUT WHAT
YOU COULD HAVE BEEN.
I HATE THIS PERSON, I HATE THAT
PERSON, THIS PERSON HATES ME.
THEN YOU GO SCREW IT.
I THINK THIS IS A CONSEQUENCE OF
POLITICS IN GENERAL.
PEOPLE ARE JUST LIKE -- >>
EXCEPT FOR THE FIVE.
>> AND TWITTER ANNOUNCED THIS
RIGHT AFTER FACEBOOK CAME OUT
WITH ITS EARNINGS.
AND I BELIEVE AOC DOES.
>> BUT
>> Juan: DIDN'T THINK
AMERICANS WERE SMART ENOUGH TO
TELL THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
LIE AND A TRUTH.
BUT I THINK WE ARE.
LOOK AT THE DOG.
HE RUNS AN AD WITH THE DOG AND
YOU SAY YOU NEED A FACT-CHECKER
TO TELL THE AMERICANS THAT THAT
IS A LIE?
COME ON.
>> Juan: I'M GOING TO DEFEND
EMILY'S MOM TO THE DEATH.
>> WE DON'T NEED YOU GUYS IN THE
MEDIA, YOU LIBERAL FACT-CHECKERS
TO TELL US WHAT'S TO KNOW ABOUT
WHAT TO SEE ON TV.
>> HE CAN SAY WHATEVER HE WANTS.
BUT HERE'S THE POINT.
DEMOCRATS ARE GETTING CRUSHED ON
RAISING MONEY AND THEY KNOW THEY
WILL GET OUTSPENT BY REPUBLICANS
AND THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
SO THEY CALLED JACK AND THEY SAY
JACK, I'M BEGGING YOU.
JACK, ABSOLUTELY.
AND JACK SAYS OKAY WE WILL DO
IT.
EVERYBODY KNOWS, POLITICAL
SPEECH IS THE SAME THING AS FREE
SPEECH AND WE DON'T WANT TWITTER
POLICING FREE SPEECH.
IT'S BEFORE ALSO BY DOING THIS
THEY MIGHT GET SOME OF THE HEAT
OFF OF HIM.
THE DEMOCRATS SAY, WE HAVE TO BE
NICE TO JACK.
>> AMERICAN SCHOOLS ARE IN
CRISIS.
IT COULD SCREEN TIME BE TO
BLAME?
DETAILS NEXT.